la parole est à présent à notre collègue
sénateur Thierry Cosic merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre ma
question porte sur l'avenir des terrains
délaissés du fait des travaux de la
ligne grande vitesse Bretagne Pays de la
Loire depuis la mise en service de la
ligne en juillet 2017 les travaux
inhérents à la création de la ligne LGV
Bretagne Pays de la Loire sont terminées
pour ce chantier SNCF réseau a acheté de
nombreux terrains les habitants et les
communes concernées devaient avoir la
possibilité de racheter ces terrains non
utilisés appelés excédent d'emprise où
il y a encore délaissée pourtant
l'importance d'un traitement dynamique
de ces sociétés de terrain délaissés par
la SNCF avaient été souligné à de
nombreuses reprises car ils étaient
susceptibles d'être remis à la
disposition des collectivités des
entreprises et des administrés
il est important de rappeler que SNCF
réseau s'est engagé auprès des communes
à prendre en charge le bornage et les
frais inhérents mais pas uniquement en
effet dans le cadre des procédures de
déclassement des voiries qui jouxtent
les terrains vendus voir les traverses
certaines communes se retrouvent
aujourd'hui encore à devoir gérer
techniquement et financièrement ces
procédures qui ont un coût alors que
cette charge relève exclusivement du
projet initié par SNCF réseau et ses
partenaires dont Eiffage des solutions
concrètes doivent être proposées aux
communes démunies et des abusées j'en
appelle à ce que les engagements pris
soient tenus les meilleurs des communes
concernées traversées par la LGV
trouvent le temps long et souhaiterait
que les que les parcelles achetées à
l'époque puissent enfin être vendus aux
personnes intéressées comme cela leur
avait été annoncé de plus les communes
ne peuvent pas établir une cartographie
précise de leur commune ce qui bloque de
nombreux dossiers et notamment un
certain nombre de successions qui sont
afférentes donc ma question est la
suivante comment comptez-vous tout faire
pour que ces terrains délaissés puissent
faire l'objet d'une remise sur le marché
en bonne et due forme
merci chers collègues la réponse c'est à
madame la ministre Dominique fort
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cosit comme voulez-vous ok
SNCF réseau a dû acquérir pour la
construction de cette ligne nouvelle des
parcelles dans l'emprise totale
indispensable pour la réalisation des
travaux ne serait pas nécessaire à terme
pour l'exploitation de la ligne lors de
la phase de conception il avait été
effectivement convenu que celle-ci une
fois les travaux terminés serait
revendus en priorité aux collectivités
concernées ou aux habitants et
entreprises des communes sur lesquelles
elles sont situées c'est délaissés
ferroviaires représentent 1000 hectares
répartis dans 56 communes à l'échelle du
projet ainsi dès 2019 SNCF réseau a
initié des procédures de revente de ces
parcelles en tenant compte de
contraintes liées aux réserves de
fonciers nécessaires au parachèvement de
la SGV et notamment la mise en oeuvre
d'un dispositif exceptionnel de lutte
contre les pics de bruit mis en place à
la demande du gouvernement pour traiter
les situations les plus sensibles sa
mise en oeuvre a pu dans cette dans
certains cas nécessite la mobilisation
de terrain déjà à qui parais SNCF réseau
et ainsi freiner les reventes de
délaissés ferroviaires toutefois à ce
jour les démarches engagées par SNCF
réseau ont significativement progresser
les ventes ou promesses de vente
représentent en effet à ce stade 80% des
terrains excédentaires recensés ces
derniers étant systématiquement proposés
en priorité aux agriculteurs riverains
de la ligne et aux communes concernées
s'agissant des frais de notaire ceux-ci
sont intégrés aux actes administratifs
de vente et pris en charge intégralement
par SNCF réseau enfin conformément à ces
engagements lors de chaque revente SNCF
réseau a fait réaliser le bornage entre
le domaine ferroviaire conservé et les
parcelles revendues
chers collègues vous avez quelques
secondes si vous souhaitez répliquer
j'ai noté vous avez parlé de 80%, moi ce
qui m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse aussi
les élus aujourd'hui c'est les 20%
restants sur lequel on assiste à une
vraie difficulté et aujourd'hui je viens
un certain nombre de maires notamment
dans la Sarthe qui sont qui sont
complètement démunis parce que ça
n'avance pas tout dépend des interlocs
des interlocuteurs qu'ils ont en phase 2
il y a des il y a des sections de la
ligne LGV où ça avançait il y en a
d'autres ou il se passe rien donc je
compte sur vous aussi pour appuyer cette
démarche